kelowna est un territoire bleus depuis
les électeurs de la circonscription
toujours choisi des députés
conservateurs
avec une seule exception en 2015 mais
même dans cette forteresse conservatrice
le nouveau chef n'est pas très connu à
des vote conservateur depuis toujours
mais pour la première fois de sa vie il
pourrait tourner le dos aux bleus il
ignore s'il est prête à donner une
chance au nouveau chef faute de ne pas
encore assez connaître et rino tall est
irrité par le style du dernier chef
angie l'échantillon n'est pas
scientifique mais à quelle aune à la
course à la direction du parti
conservateur ne semble pas avoir soulevé
les passions
celui-ci lui a donné son appui à irin au
tour durant la course
lorsqu'ils prendront le temps de nous
connaître les députée conservatrice
locale croit que les électeurs
apprécieront son côté terre à terre et
près de leurs préoccupations mais à
kelowna comme ailleurs au pays
le chef conservateur pourra toutefois
continuer de profiter de l'appui d'une
base solide
si les militants conservateurs vante la
qualité de son travail sur le terrain
l'apport des mythes comme et 19 pourrait
empêcher une autre d'aller à la
rencontre des électeurs comme il
l'entend l'un des nombreux défis qui se
dressent sur sa route vers le pouvoir
ici mathieu gaye et radio canada kelowna